Hi, I'm John Green, this is Crash Course World
History and today we’re going to talk about
a relationship. No, not you, college girlfriend.
No, not that kind of relationship either.
No. STAN, THIS IS A HISTORY CLASS. We’re
gonna talk about the relationship between
a city, Venice, and an empire, the Ottomans,
and in doing so, we're going to return to
an old theme here on Crash Course World History:
How studying history can make you a better
boyfriend and/or girlfriend. Probably or,
but I’m not here to judge.
Mr. Green! Mr. Green! No offense, but you don’t really
seem like an expert in how to get girls to like you.
Here’s something amazing, Me From the Past.
You know that girl, Sarah, in 10th grade,
who’s super super smart?
Yeah, she’s really hot. She’s like three
or four leagues hotter than I am.
Yeah, I married her. So shut up and listen.
[theme music]
Ten minutes from now, I’m hoping you’ll understand
how one mutually beneficial relationship, between
the Venetians and the Ottomans, led to two really
big deals: the European Renaissance and Christopher
Columbus. Not like his birth, I mean he wasn't
like a half-Ottoman, half-Venetian baby, his travels!
So Venice is a city made up of hundreds of
islands at the northern tip of the Adriatic
Sea, but walking around it, you can’t help
but feel that the city is essentially a collection
of floating buildings tied together by some
canals. If ever there was a place where geography
was destiny, it was Venice. Venice was literally
built for ocean-going trade. As you can imagine,
Venice didn’t have a lot of natural resources
— except for fish and mustaches — so if
they wanted to grow, they had to rely on trade.
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
First, Venetians became experts in shipbuilding.
Remember that when the crusaders needed ships
for their crazy Fourth Crusade, they headed
to Venice, because the Venetians were famous
for their ships, including merchant ships
like the galley and the cog. Not only could
they build ships; they could also sail them
to pleasant locales like Constantinople and
the Levant, so the Venetians formed trade
treaties, sometimes called concessions, with
the Byzantines, and then when Constantinople
fell to the Ottomans and became Istanbul,
the Venetians were quick to make trade treaties
with their new neighbors, famously saying
that while Istanbul had been Constantinople,
the matter of Constantinople getting the works
was nobody’s business but the Turks.
But even before the Ottomans, Venice had experience
trading with the Islamic world: It initially
established itself as the biggest European
power in the Mediterranean thanks to its trade
with Egypt’s sultan in the outlandishly
lucrative pepper business. Can’t blame the
Europeans, really, that stuff is delicious.
Oh, you mean like actual pepper? Ah, that’s
good too, especially since it masks the taste
of spoiled meat, which most meat was in the
days before refrigeration. Due to some awkward…
Crusades… the Egyptian merchants weren't
terribly welcome in…ya know...Europe. But
they had all the pepper, because the Egyptians
imported it from India and controlled both
overland and oversea access to the Mediterranean.
And when others cited moral or religious opposition
to trade, the Venetians usually found a way.
Which is why the whole freaking town is made
of marble. Thanks, Thought Bubble.
To avoid the sticky situation of having to
consort with the heathen Egyptians, the Venetians
employed a handy story. This is the Piazza
San Marco, the #1 Destination in the Entire
World for People Who Like to Be Pooped on
by Pigeons. It’s also home to this church,
which includes some bronze horses you may
remember that were looted from Constantinople.
And it contains the body of St. Mark, author
of the Gospel According to St. Mark, who had
once been the bishop of Alexandria, in Egypt.
So naturally he died and was buried in Alexandria,
but the Venetians claimed him as their own,
because apparently one time he visited Venice,
and these two merchants hatched a very clever
plan. They went to Alexandria on business,
stole St. Mark’s body and then hid it in
a shipment of pork, which the Muslims didn’t check very
carefully because, you know, they were disgusted by it.
You can even see a version of this on the
mosaics in the Basilica of St. Mark, complete
with the Muslims shouting an Arabic version
of “ewww gross.” And then, forever after,
the Venetians were like, “Listen, we HAVE
to trade with these guys. We use it as a secret
way to ferry saint bodies out of Egypt. We
don’t WANT to become fantastically wealthy.
It’s just a necessary byproduct of our saint-saving.”
So what did Venice import? Lots, but notable
for us, they imported a lot of grain, because
if you've ever been to Venice, then you might
have noticed that it is basically made out
of marble and therefore kind of difficult
to farm. The Ottomans, on the other hand,
had abundant grain, even before they conquered
Egypt and its oh-so-fertile Nile River in
1517. Also, while trade was certainly the
linchpin of Venice’s economic success, they
had a diverse economy. They also produced
things like textiles and glass. And in fact,
Venice is still known for its glass, but they
couldn’t produce it without a special ash
that they used to make the colors. And you’ll
never guess where the ash came from. The Ottomans.
Am I making you a better boyfriend yet? You
have to add to your partner’s life. You
have to color their glass. That sounds like
a euphemism. but it’s not-- BACK TO HISTORY.
One last thing about Venice that makes it
special, at least for its time. Venice was
a republic, not a monarchy or, god forbid,
an empire. So its leaders were elected, and
had to answer to the populace- I mean, at
least the property-owning male populace. The
ruler was the doge and he got to live in a
very nice house and wear a funny hat.
The Sultan of the Ottoman empire also got
to live in a nice house and wear a funny hat,
but there the similarities end. To begin,
the Ottomans were an empire that lasted from
around 1300 CE until 1919, making it one of
the longest-lasting and richest empires in
world history. The Ottomans managed to blend
their pastoral nomadic roots with some very
un-nomadic empire building, and some really
impressive architecture, like this and this
and this, making them very different from,
wait for it, the Mongols.
The empire, or at least the dynasty, was founded
by Osman Bey, and Ottoman is a Latinization
of Osmanli, which basically means like the
House of Osman. No, Stan, the house, y-, yes.
Oh my Gosh. The Ottomans were greatest in
the 15th and 16th centuries under two famous
sultans: First, Mehmed the Conqueror ruled
from 1451 to 1481 and expanded Ottoman control
to the Balkans, which is why there are Bosnian
Muslims today. But Ottoman expansion reached
its greatest extent under Suleiman the Magnificent,
who ruled from 1520 to 1566. He took valuable
territory in Mesopotamia and Egypt, thus securing
control over the western parts of the Asian
trade – both overland and oversea. He also
defeated the king of Hungary and laid siege
to Vienna in 1526. And he turned the Ottomans
into a huge naval power. Also, judging from
his hat, he had the largest brain in human
history.
The Ottomans basically controlled about half
of what the Romans controlled, but it was
much more valuable because of all the Indian
Ocean trade you’ll remember from last week.
So all this land brought a lot of wealth,
but it needed to be ruled. The Ottomans could
have followed the Roman model, where you send
out generals and nobles to rule over conquered
territories, or they could’ve demanded the
allegiance of client kings like the Persians,
or developed a civil service system like the
Chinese, but instead, they created an entirely
new ruling class, a system that some historians
call the slave aristocracy.
So if you are a King, one of your main problems
is hereditary nobles, because they always
want to replace you, and they don’t want
to give you your money, & they want their
ugly sons to marry your gorgeous daughters,
etc. One way to deal with this problem is
to make them part of the government so they
feel included and shut up. Another way is
to kill them. That’s what they usually do in Russia.
I’m whispering so Putin doesn’t hear me. Ahh! Putin!
The Ottomans just bypassed the problem of
hereditary nobles altogether by creating both
an army and a bureaucracy from scratch so
they would be loyal only to the Sultan. How?
The devshirme, a program in which they kidnapped
Christian boys, converted them to Islam, and
raised them either to be members of an elite
military fighting force called the Janissaries,
or to be government bureaucrats. Incidentally,
which of those gigs would you prefer? Because
I think that says a lot about you as a person.
Either way, you weren’t allowed to have
kids, which prevented the whole hereditary
nobles problem, and also ensured that the
Ottoman government would contain quite a lot
of Eunuchs. Oh, it’s time for the Open Letter?
An Open Letter to Ottoman Eunuchs. But first,
let’s see what’s in the secret compartment
today. Oh, its a blow up globe. See what quitting
smoking will get you, Me From the Past?
Hey there Ottoman Eunuchs, How’s it hanging?
I’m just kidding, that was mean. Listen,
there’ve been eunuchs all around this great
planet of ours. But you’re special. I’m
not going to give you the details why, because
they’re horrifying. I’m just going to
link to an article in the video info.
You started out just being harem guards, Ottoman
Eunuchs, which is kind of an obvious gig for
you, but then, you expanded. As had happened
in China, you made yourselves indispensable,
and you were often the center of palace intrigue.
In fact, few people in the Ottoman Empire
were as wealthy and important as many of you
were. Way to turn lemons into lemonade. I’m
sorry, I shouldn’t have brought up lemons.
Best wishes, John Green
This system eventually broke down as Janissaries
(who had guns) lobbied to be allowed to have
families. But until that happened, the Ottomans
system of using a mix of slave administrators
and Eunuchs to run everything worked incredibly
well. But to return to the relationship between
the Ottomans and the Venetians: After the
Ottomans captured Egypt, they pretty much
controlled the flow of trade through the Mediterranean,
but the Venetians had centuries of experience
as mariners, and also lots of boats. Speaking
of ships, I ship these guys. So the Ottomans
were content to let the Venetians do all the like,
trading and carrying of goods, and they just made
their money from taxes. And that worked because both
Venice and the Ottomans added value to each other.
Healthy relationships — listen up, Me From
the Past — aren’t about extracting value;
they have to be mutually beneficial to work.
And boy, was that a mutually beneficial relationship.
For instance, Venice became super rich, and
being super rich was a prerequisite for the
European Renaissance because all that art
and learning required money, which is why
Venice was a leading city at the beginning
of the European Renaissance before being eclipsed
by Florence, Rome, and I don’t know, say
Rotterdam.
Also, this relationship established firm connections
between Europe and Islamic world, which allowed
ideas to flow again especially old Greek  that ideas
had preserved and built upon by Muslims. I mean,
I guess those connections had existed for a long time,
but crusades aren’t a great way to exchange ideas.
But perhaps the most crucial result of the
Venetian and Ottoman control of trade was
that it forced other Europeans to look for
different paths to the riches of the East.
And that fueled huge investments in exploration.
The Portuguese sailed south and east around
the southern tip of Africa, and the Spanish
went west, believing that the Indies and China
were much closer than they turned out to be.
Thanks for watching. I’ll see you next week.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller, our script supervisor is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by my high school history
teacher Raoul Meyer and myself. And our graphics
team is Thought Bubble. Last week’s Phrase
of the Week was: "Unfortunately they didn't
have pizza." If you want to suggest future
phrases of the week or guess at this week’s,
you can do so in comments where you can also
ask questions about today's video that will
be answered by our team of historians.
Thanks for watching Crash Course. And as we
say in my hometown, Don't Forget To Be Awesome.